you know it baby you know it and you
don't isn't that fascinating
um you know i remember when i was young
they had a fella in my neighborhood this
little boy named little allen
and god damn he was small brother he
couldn't even he he he couldn't even put
a large grape in his mouth
i mean he yeah yeah he had to shove it
in
and he was on every prayer list my god
he was just
a young fellow just monopolized
prayerless around every day every prayer
list allen allen
allen hugging and alan times too
just man so many prayers went up for
small island man and
you know i'm thinking about him i know
uh that actually today is his birthday
and that is january 14
in the year 2021 that's where we are
i don't know i i don't know if you're
bill or ted
but we're in the future i don't know if
your tamara
i don't know hell i don't know who you
are because i don't know you
i do not know you
but it's a wild one out there man they
need to start making underpants thicker
because
[ __ ] is getting real
let's get into it
[Music]
come on thinking oh there's no way he's
going to play it again huh
well
i'm just sitting on your front post
wondering how could i be so far
from mine oh come on
tell them travis and my mind is
somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
come on baby
now i'm just floating on the breeze
[Music]
come
a little on
for me to set that parking brake and
let myself unwind shine that light on
me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and that you know that's bishop gun
shine
and you want to put somebody in your
prayer let's put that band on it right
there
you know they got so close to uh real
stardom they really got close to it
and it really and and it fell apart
you know it's hard to it's hard to you
know they really had it for a moment i
mean they had it them boys they were
opening up for the rolling stones there
and that's not a geometric deal that is
a famous musical
act or you know group talent quadrant
and um and um
and they were opening up for them and
damn dallas
one of the probably 15 20 biggest cities
opening up for the roast toes baby
and they let it all fall through the
fingers man
but for a moment for a moment they had
it
you know it's interesting to think
sometimes how small a moment is
you know there's moments in my life
where i want to
[Music]
you know i just want to hold on to it i
want to you know want to capture the mo
i want to
it could be a birthday party
and you blowing out a candle when you
seeing that flame go out and you catch
the eye of a real fine
match in the d stunts
and you want that moment to last you
want to know hey baby
i'm [ __ ] cutting the flame off these
[ __ ]
off these confectioners right here off
these sugar [ __ ] squadrons baby i
you know i got us you want to look her
in the eyes and say look
there's more sweet where this came from
yeah
you know and you want to hold that
moment
remember when i was young when i was a
child they had um
a little area by us it was a little
preschool
and my mom said point blank you want to
go to preschool and i said do i have to
go she said no
and i said well let me up in that [ __ ]
let me see what they doing in that [ __ ]
now let me see what they doing in that
[ __ ]
damn mom
and i went in and they wasn't doing much
they let anybody in preschool
now college is different you got a test
to get into it
but for preschool you just gotta have
some mfr drop you off before 7 a.m
that was the only you know
that was the act that was it could you
get out of a station wagon
before 7 a.m
then you qualify
and we we'd get in there we sit on the
carpet
they had a square carpet and it had all
the numbers and letters on it
or at least most of them i didn't know
all of them
i probably knew to about l
and they had definitely one through zero
on it going up to nine and then
zero and people would sit there and add
one television they played different
cartoons on it they played uh
um gummy bears on it
and gum now it's a damn sugar treat when
i was young gummy bears was a damn
hell it was a [ __ ] it was a program
these were you know these were
as a child you thought maybe you might
meet them one day in the woods
and now it's a damn you know it's
something they sell you know it looks
like a damn bait
they sell it you know they sell it at
the checkout but
you know it's a basic snack it's barely
a damn sugar snack
[ __ ] looks japanese really
but we enjoyed that man gummy bear
but we would sit there and some kids
would piss themselves some kid didn't
even know how to work their bladder
their parents would bring them there and
they'd just piss out
unbelievable
and i remember outside in the schoolyard
there they had a little somebody cut
down a tree
and about three feet of it left up out
of the ground
and i remember one kid ran and jumped
over it
this little fella named mikey and they
called him roger but
his name was mikey but they called him
roger
but um he ran and jumped over it and i
thought i can do that
i could run and jump over that
but i didn't really have the same
gymnetics
i'd never seen gymnetics as mikey roger
baby and i
you know you know my my father was in
his 70s my mother was delivered cookies
at the time
and uh you know that's not the real
makeup of a damn
preschool gayle sayers
so i ran i jumped and
at the time i barely had a real
i mean i barely had an earl grey of a
nut sack
and it caught on to the damn you know
whatever tree that was and somebody had
undeniably cut the tree down for
christmas it was
this was right after christmas and
somebody cut that [ __ ] down and got it
home and realized it was like a damn
hickory or a baby maple
and said f it and just put it in the
yard but um
but damn boy if i didn't snag
the lord's eyelid baby in my nutsack on
that thing and
and that hurt man um
but yeah you know that's preschool and
it's
uh it's hit or miss baby it's hit or
miss
what's going on with you guys oh i gotta
tell you we have the
and i'm excited thank you guys for being
here today um
fresh off that dust emporia episode
i think i realized i i've just i turned
into too much of a dustin
fan to maybe talk with him sometimes i
just such a
you know i'm just a fan of so much of
who he is as a person
and uh and as a friend he's been a good
friend to me and
um you know we've we've kind of we've
developed a friendship over the years
some and
i'm not going to say we're best friends
or nothing like dad do because you know
uh
i'm an adult and we don't really have
best friends at this age but um
but he you know obviously i'm a fan
undeniably
and i'm just excited for him and it was
just i was just so
excited to have him on and just like you
know i was just grateful that he gave me
that time this guy's about to
this man's in abu dhabi you man
this man's in the desert baby he's out
there about to sand wrestling that sand
casa
he's about to castle roll you feel me
um and i just you know he's got to get
counter to the ground i think but well
you know and i want to sit there and
sell it but i don't know
i don't know some bit some bad [ __ ]
over there the uh
nashville mma put me into a damn figure
nine last week
so what you know i can't even answer the
phone in one of my one of my hands is
all
stagnant because of whatever she did to
me damn hexed me
so i you know i'm all i can do is just
we cheer
and but win or lose the man's a champion
and i was just honored to be in his
presence
that's honestly how i feel
what's going on um what was i thinking
about
oh we have the show and it is
friday night january 15th 8 p.m
you know i i'm so i'm just excited to be
able to do this with chelsea
and uh and we're just gonna try to make
it fun and to try something new
you know i realize um
i realize that sometimes i you know i
get it's hard to try something
new sometimes as life gets going oh well
i know what it's gonna be like well uh
you know what if people don't like me
after it what if
you know what if um it's not what i'm
used to
um and i have some thoughts like that
but i'm just trying to lean into it
and i'm trying to embrace it
you know just grab the mole by the damn
mole skin
and just shake that and yeah
but yeah we have sketches you can get a
ticket and a ticket means you just you
can watch it
it's a 10 ticket you can sit there eight
p.m central standard time january 15th
and watch it at home and it's going to
be live we are
going live um
we got trey lewis will be performing uh
larry fleet you heard him on here where
i find god he will be performing live
uh we have some sketches that are gonna
be live we have some sketches
uh that we've already put together we
have a talent show
with some real illegitimate talents
and legitimate and illegitimate
i mean orphans of talents like i'm
talking talents that have never met
their parents
i'm talking to them kind of talented
redheaded talents and uh
it's just gonna be something so
um what else is going on man
oh i had a damn dome my god i had a
donut
you know i had a oh man i had it done
you ever had a doughnut where you just
were your eat i mean the whole time i'm
eating it all i could hear my
head i could hear that song uh i bet
they can't i bet you can't do it like me
i bet you can't do it like me
oh i bet you can't do it like me
i think it's like a rap song of you know
it's an urban real that buddhist checker
but you can do it like me you know i
mean this thing
man i put a
look and i cut this thing into quarters
because i knew out the gate this was a
bad [ __ ] this little donut
this little sugar cinderella this [ __ ]
about to [ __ ]
turn into a damn taste gasm at midnight
at the stroke of 12 in my mouth this
thing
i could i cut it into quarters
and that's how old i am if somebody asks
you how old you are you say well i'm at
the age where i
will cut a doughnut in the quarters
and that's a that's an interesting age
baby
that's an interesting age out there and
i cut this back i mean this [ __ ] was
from atlanta
you know what i'm saying this was about
that life but you can't do it like me
this [ __ ] was about that life uh
you know i mean this [ __ ] had a couple
gunshots on her you know a couple
gun uh gun shots and her thigh she was
about that life
and i cut that thing into quarters and i
had it man it's from five daughters
bakery it was in uh
out here in the central east and it was
oh
oh my god
this thing made me wanna damn
i had to check with the lord and make
sure we was good after that thing
because it was good man
but that show is friday uh it's gonna
have sketches live music
um a talent show you know it's just it's
a live show and that's what's
interesting about these days
that you can do a show and to put it
straight into people
you know i i i don't have to go to some
big fancy man up there
or some fancy woman wishing she was a
man
at a company somewhere and and saying
hey hey hey
hey hey hey mr andy hey hey
mr yavil mr barbara
can i do the show no you can't
that's gone and now you can go direct
and so it's just going to be a nice time
if you can't be there for uh
8 p.m on friday
central standard time you will be able
to get the show for a week or 10 days
after you still be able to go online
and uh and watch it but i'm excited it's
going to be a new adventure i'm trying
something
new and we've been working really really
hard uh
to put on something good so i'm really
grateful to um
i'm just grateful to everybody that's
been helping me
support for the podcast is brought to
you by
manscaped and it look
you're if you're a man you better be
scaped out
you can't be bringing no you know them
hair and nuts out there
to the ladies anymore they won't accept
it
you show up with that little hair bag
maybe you show up and your
your nuts is all braided on the sides
[ __ ]
you know you show up in your nuts have a
crazy fade they got a ms-13 tattoo right
there
yeah nah those days are over
but what i'm telling you about is
manscaped
who knew smelling this good could feel
this good too
well manscape did that's why they
released a new cologne
and a lot of men in prison use manscape
did you know that
i want to tell you this a lot of times
your balls will they be wilin bro
if you ever been on a bus or something
the bus got abandoned on the side of the
road
along the long island expressway that
l.i.e
and you've been up all night anyway
doing dope and you out there and your
nuts is sitting right there under you
people don't realize that the whole time
you blowing a bag of blow
you know you know the whole time you
freaking snout wrestling an eight ball
your nuts is right there with you bro
suffering staying up all night
they wanted to get some rest maybe they
going to see their aunt
maybe they're going to see their cousin
tomorrow but not today not now
because they've been up all night riding
your coke habit
with the same signature scent that's in
all manscape formulas
this cologne is a perfect complement to
the collection
light approachable and gentlemanly in
all the right ways get your body right
with good scent
calming and inviting this signature
scent introduces a light citrus burst
[Music]
before settling in the anchoring notes
of vitaeva in a woodsy masculine finish
and we know that vetiver uh
is a grass that only grows in hawaii and
now you can use the new manscape refined
cologne to complete your set and smell
great anytime anywhere
it's time to feel sexy quit feeling
homeless
quit feeling like you just had nine
pence of ice cream
it's time to feel sexy get 20 off and
free shipping go to
dot com manscape.com theo get 20
off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
theo support the podcast that's 20 off
free shipping by going to manscaped.com
theo look good smell good feel good with
manscaped
i'ma let you know also quickly after the
year we've all been through
saving money should be at the top of
everyone's resolution list some people
use
you see their list and there's crazy
stuff up there
my friend wrote down go hot ballooning
i'm like you i said you mean hot air
ballooning is that what you mean quincy
say oh yeah man well then write that
quincy
because you wrote hot ballooning
and you put a lighter to a balloon
and you're hanging under from a basket
son and you die
and that's death so that's what you're
looking to do quincy oh man i don't know
so if you're still paying insane amounts
of money every month for wireless
what are you doing what what are you
doing
switch to mint mobile it's the easiest
way to save this year
and get out of those big boys pocket as
the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
lets you maximize your savings
with plans starting at just fifteen
dollars a month
for people looking for extra savings
this year mint mobile
offers premium wireless for just 15
bucks a month
switch to mint mobile get premium
wireless if you're not satisfied
a hundred percent satisfied that means
premier full
top top satisfaction mint mobile has you
covered
with their seven money money-back
guarantee
and you know i like a guarantee because
it's something
that's exactly what it is to get your
new wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month
and get the plans shipped to your door
for free go to mint
dot com slash t-h-e-o that's mint mobile
dot com slash t-h-e-o cut your wireless
bill
to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com
slash theo thanks you thanks you thanks
you mint mobile
oh what else um
yeah we got the show on uh on friday you
can get a ticket in the links below we
have um
you know i uh
i was singing when i was young they had
we used to go to this place bj's
and um some people think it means blow
jobs but we don't know what it meant
but they sold uh pizza
you know round italian
and we would go over there and mom would
take us over there
and they had a lot of little teams in
there you know the bobcats a little
softball or something
or they have a little handicap little
you know uh
you know hot wheels little handicapped
uh
kickball team or something they'd be in
there them [ __ ] you know we come and
we
and we never played [ __ ] we'd just be in
there our family
and they had bad pizza over there in
covington louisiana they had bad pizza
then the middle was real wet
and the middle was real wet
and on some things you want a wet middle
but uh pete's saying but uh pete's ain't
one of them
so we'd be in there and you know
we had our allowance and we'd earned it
mom usually kept more than
my we usually earned more than we got
my mom had this allowance system where
you never got it all
and um and shout out to my voice uh
patrick out there and he uh he one time
won a family
football pool it was his whole family 40
50 members
when we were in like third grade he won
it
and he won like twelve hundred dollars
this is a long time ago
and his mother convinced him to buy a
christmas village
and so he didn't know any better you
know he's damn nine
and so he bought it he picked all the
team's stand for texas tech
old dominion he'd picked it all michigan
and by the by after he'd wanted them
twelve hundred dollars
which is like four thousand dollars
today and his mother
he said my mom want that money she said
well we should invest it
and she made him buy a damn christmas
village
that you put out on the table
and if you think their relationship is
booming today then
you don't know big business
um but i remember we go over there bj's
pizza and that video games in there and
you had to get the manager sometimes the
pinball wouldn't work well
you had to get the manager over there
this fella to come and put the ball
if you know the ball would disappear and
he this guy always had a couple extra on
him
and the guy honestly homosexual i'll be
honest bro
and i didn't know at the time i was like
oh he's just friendly he likes to touch
my neck and back a lot and he's you know
oh a lot older and
you know uh and he wears deodorant on
his arms
full arm but now i know what i'm saying
basically i'm a sex
or home they call them homeowners and i
don't but they do but i
sometimes i do
and um we're talking about uh
i don't even know um
oh mom would take us over there and we'd
get us a little bit of allowance we'd
have our allowance and then mom they had
a little uh venomous
uh video gaming machine legalized video
gambling you know slots little
and it was the one the early ones that
just had the cards it was just the
five cards you hold a couple and we'd be
dude i'd be damned ten years old
up against they had those you know those
double those western doors
and in there they had three little
setups
and somebody there's always somebody
been had pissed back behind a couple of
the machines or whatever but that was
nothing we didn't see it
but you knew it'd happen it was that
kind of place
and um and my mom would go in and we'd
give her her
her our allowance and tell her what to
bet on pick three pick nine pick the
queen
and uh and we lost it all
we lost it all as a family though
and you know there's ways to the
there's a difference losing it all alone
and there's a difference losing it all
together
it just it just uh it hits different
but but yeah that was bj's pizza man and
then we'd have a little mom we go
next door that had a place called
mackenzie's a bakery
famous bakery and they ended up having a
family ended up having a damn fire and
somebody burned to death with all the uh
best rest
recipes you know but that's that's
louisiana man
and um we go over there and get a little
sugar treat man
little confection or treat you know we'd
each have a quarter and we could get you
a little something bro
you know get your little baby eclair
nighttime eclair they call them
full of chocolate on it i'll get you a
little one of those
so now every now and then we'd [ __ ] up
and get a meringue bro
oh nothing sadder than seeing some
healthy little kids some dirty little
hey little dirty hands
eating a damn [ __ ] little french
man look like a damn look like
napoleon's uh
appendix these little things you know
just
piece of [ __ ] man but uh
what else dude what else is even going
on now we we
we've been working all day on the on the
show for friday so that's really the big
thing that's going on
um got some exciting guests
so that's good uh
yeah that's it you guys sent in some
calls
um i'm feeling happy to be alive i want
to share that you know i think sometimes
i don't share
that i am excited to be living in god's
world bro
i'm excited to be living in whoever
created this
i'm happy to be in here right now and um
i gotta remember to say that on the days
when i'm feeling it because
i don't always feel it as you well know
and so i have to remember to share that
out loud
so i hope you're doing well um
and yeah and i really do i hope you're
just
rolling with the punches there's a lot
going on right
now out there
but when i make my world small
and connect with the people that i care
about there's
nothing too different going on
you know if anything in some ways these
times have been have helped me to make
my life kind of smaller
um and so i have two options then
i can enjoy that or i cannot enjoy that
and for today i'm trying to enjoy that
and i feel like i
am so that's good man amen bro
praise god bam ptl baby
all right let's take a couple couple
calls you guys couple calls have hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
as always is the hotline here on the
371st
episode of this past weekend man that's
crazy
um that's really crazy oh i want to tell
i want to uh
if there's a memory you know and my
family would go to bj's pizza over there
and years later i would work there my
brother would work there
you know we got him but there was a
class action suit there was a fire we
were
we went through all of that i you know i
saw some good
i you know i saw some
you know i saw some things i shouldn't
have seen over there i saw some things i
should have seen
you know i ended up getting i got a job
there years later i got fired
you know i've told the story i was me
and the other uh dishwasher had a
contest who could hold our head under
the dishwater
the longest you know basic
you know mono imano type deal
and i was down there i'm on down there
40 seconds 42
43 and the seconds get hot bro
when you ride in dish water brother [ __ ]
get i mean it's not only you can feel
the grease building on your shirt but
you feel the ability you're almost a
champion
you know this little [ __ ] ass jason
only has about 39 seconds so i'm riding
dirty now
so i keep going at 43 seconds i rip my
head up out of the water and i yell
straight up
champion and the boss had come in at the
time wild wayne they called him
and i'll say this every wayne somehow
gets called wild wayne which is [ __ ]
they need to definitely see how much of
these wanes
is wild because many are not
and this man was not wild
you know he banged kind of a thick gal
and he uh
and he smoked an rip also but um
i can't remember oh but i yelled
champion the bosses right there fired me
on the spot
but anyway what was your favorite place
to eat growing up if you had a favorite
meal time you went
you know uh before that when my father
still lived with us we went to pizza hut
and it was a it was a damn four star
four and a quarter
four and a quarters ours it was a four
and a quarter star establishment when i
was young
and if you go sit in there the thick red
plastic cups
with the crushed ice nobody was doing
crushed ice
nobody was doing crushed ice
and pizza did it man and people forget
that [ __ ]
a lot of people nowadays they see p you
know they just think it's baskin robbins
freaking little pervy uncle bro
but they was more than that
and we would go and have the salad bar
that pudding on a salad bar
do people would pay for the salad bar
just
fun of pudding
that's my sebastian maniscalco people
would pay for
a salad bar
yes
i love you sebastian man um
but yeah what was a restaurant that you
hit that you loved give me a tell me a
little bit about it
maybe you and your father would hit
hardee's in the morning
maybe i'll hit a tim horton
maybe you guys would hit a kfc in
shanghai because everything over there
is a real
[ __ ] but uh
but what would you hit tell me let me in
on it 985-664-9503
um you know there was a death at the
comedy store this week uh
a man died
a man died and a man died
you know a man died and
and he died
he died and the man named jeff
and jeff was a pianist at the comedy
store and he was probably
i mean he was human furniture really he
was a
he was like a water fountain of that
place
and i meant that because he would really
he would he kind of spit a lot when he
talked but also because he was a fixture
you know he was he was just a beloved
man he was the pianist
and when you brought up on stage when he
broke when you came up on stage he would
play you up
and you know as comedians we're so much
in our head we're in our own ego a lot
of times so once they call your name
it's just
you feel your body walking up there and
then you feel your body grabbing the mic
i would always say you guys give it up
for jeff over here
you know he's blind i would say
and um and he wasn't blind you know
but he would pretend he was blind you
know he would just kind of blind out
and uh and he did it every time every
time i got on stage there it was just
this little moment that he and i had
and um and i know that sounds crazy but
it was just this thing that was
a constant and we would have some nice
chats you know he would always tell me
nice things you know hey man this thing
this bit you're doing is really
it's good yeah you're doing a good job
just keep doing what you're doing
nobody's doing
what you're doing and he made me feel
hopeful
you know he gave me a lot of hope
and he also gave me he gave me a rape
whistle also
but um
but yeah he died you know he died
and uh
and he died and he died and um
he died like three four days ago
and it really breaks my heart man
because part of me wonders
did he die from
just the separation you know i think he
was 60 or 70 years old he might have
been 75 years
old and part of me wonders how much of a
man how much can a man's
you know with no connection
like how many more people are we losing
from code because of
disconnection
and i don't know if we'll know the
repercussions of some of that
you know especially a lot of people that
struggle with addiction and struggle
with
um those sorts of you know in all types
of addiction you know it's like
when we isolate it can be really not
good
and so i wonder how many
how many people just stuck in their own
little worlds without some reflection in
the universe to let them know that
they're good or they're okay
you know as much as jeff played us on
his keys and brought us up there every
night
uh we everybody looked over at him and
smiled
everybody acknowledged him he'd go blow
a joint you know
he was gassed up so on that dude he
missed half of his work
you'd get off stage and and be ready to
bring up the next person he went even
there
he literally had to work like 12
one minute spots throughout the night
and he would probably make about eight
of them
um
but it was just he came there and he
just everybody loved him he was this
weird
like you know sometimes he throw one of
those little rubber balls and it just
goes it just goes
and it's bouncing off thin this and it's
bouncing
and he was like that he just touched
everybody
um
and and he had crazy stories man he he
he got aids bro he got aids and he
you know and i would even joke from
stage you know jeff right here y'all
give it up for jeffy's terminally ill
you know and uh
and he got a's man and i think that's
brave as hell people say you know
you know say this and that about aids
but i think that's that's brave as hell
man and um
he has a great episode with brian
scalaro that is out and he had recorded
it five days before his death and
you can go listen to that we'll put the
link as that as that as well
in in below
and man he you know
and he just he used to tell me about
being young and being in a place called
provincetown and it was
real gay you know real like kind of gay
hit men
dude come up and just stab you six or
seven times with that peter bro
with that wayner that kind of place you
know
you trying to buy a soda and they give
you half a cup of cop
you know when he said he got taken
advantage some and
and then he ended up out in los angeles
and uh
and he thought his life was going to end
but his life really began when he got
out there
and i didn't really know that i would
care as much
not to say that meaningless you just
don't know when some people leave the
earth how much it's going to hit you and
it just you know it didn't
it just made me realize how different
things are going to be and how much
a lot of people might be struggling
um
[Music]
you know and i didn't i didn't ever know
you know he really i mean i just for him
just wake up and be positive every day
and having gay aids man
and to just be to show up every day
you know and uh
and that's you know
and that's really the that blood ghost
baby aids
and um
yeah i just want to say thank you jeff
man you know we love
you bro
and you were nice and you were warm and
you were kind and
[Music]
you didn't ever be wild or try to [ __ ]
or do anything wild like that you just
you know you gave homestead to people
that needed it
um
and i i felt like you would have shared
with anybody you would have shared your
time
and i wish i had spent more time with
you brother
you know i wish i got to know you a
little bit better man uh
you know and we love you jeff jeff scott
i want to let you know that
oh man um yeah sorry i didn't mean to
get off like that but
uh you know life is just this
it's like
life is just like this
life's like this it's like a like an
outfit or a costume or a coat
and the second i start to kind of feel
like i know what it feels like
it it turns into like a
just a different
and i can never
i can never wear it right i can never
know how i look in it i can never
i can never know if it fits really it's
just brief
moments of know of of life feeling
tailored
um before it completely readjust man
and god bless you jeff scott man and uh
yeah we love you bro
you know i don't know if you know and i
don't know what you were going through
when you were at home and you were by
you know
for you know what was going on you know
and i'm sorry that uh you and i weren't
closer
but i just didn't realize how big of a
part you were in my life and of a lot of
other people's lives man
and i'm happy that i got to um cross
paths with you
on this realm brother gang
um i want to let you know if you've ever
had acne baby
adult acne or whatever middle age acne
that um
and you're looking to get clear skin
that you can do it now
become a proactive subscriber
get the clear skin feeling that's what
you want you definitely want that
proactive acne treatment systems have
clinically proven ingredients
to clear skin and their dermatologist
tested to be gentle you don't want some
[ __ ] hit man some joe pesci up there
ryan
with your skin you want a damn you know
you want somebody up there baby you want
a kate moss up there
you know doing some soft coke off your
skin you want somebody taking care of
you
look we all have stresses in life
from little to big stresses i had so
much acne when i was young
i was afraid to smile at people
because my skin would tighten it would
pop a zit
that crazy afraid to raise my eyebrows
because it would pop a zit them all and
i'm afraid the
white you know the white in my skin is
gonna you know a chunk of white will
shoot off at abroad
or a teacher or somebody acne is
dangerous
you have stubborn breakouts no problem
sensitive skin types with occasional
pimples
no problem proactive has you covered
combining gentle skin care with
clinically proven acne fighting
ingredients
proactive has three different systems
designed for your skin type proactive
solution
proactive plus and proactive md
right now is a great time to try
proactive
look you've tried other things in your
past or maybe you you've just let life
go on and not
cared about your skin take a moment to
care about yourself slow things down
for our podcast listeners you can get a
special
limited time offer by going to
proactive.com
theo subscribe today and you will
receive proactive's hydrating duo
as a free gift that includes four
hydrogel masks
and the green tea moisturizer best of
all you get free shipping
that's right free shipping again visit
proactive
p r o a c t i v
dot com slash theo to take advantage of
this special
offer now that's proactive.com and
subscribe to consistently
clear skin look how you should look at
the static out of your skin
oh i'm gonna tell you about this right
now um
let's take a call
let's take a call uh
hey theo how you doing this is ali out
in dubai uh hope you're doing
what's up ally in dubai my brother and
i'm
i'm envious of you and take care of uh
michael chandler and dustin poirier when
they're over there
and take care of dan hooker and conor
mcgregor
and take care of all them boys and over
there knuckle tussling man gang praise
god brother onward
well i wanted to get your thoughts on
hamster healthcare
uh you're the resident hamster expert as
we all know
and i wanted to give you a quick uh call
to
get your thoughts about how we should be
treating hamsters when they're sick
so amen brother and um
this ought to be interesting let's go
brother onward long story short
my wife bought my kids a couple of dwarf
hamsters about a year ago
so okay yeah and that's roborovskies man
dwarf dwarf hamsters are roborovskies
and they're small and they're real cute
they look uh
almost like somebody just you know
tickled a uh
marshmallow and put eyes in it onward
they're like hamsters but
smaller uh hence the name dwarf and
one of them got sick a couple weeks ago
a few weeks ago
his eyes swelled up and my kids thought
he was blind in one eye and i said okay
just give him a patch
uh give him a little cane he'll be okay
uh
or send them outside and let the
neighborhood cats have their way and let
nature take its course
but my wife thought no we gotta take him
to the vet so
we got into a little bit and then she
took him to the vet the vet hit us with
some
uh dwarf hamster health care which cost
me about a hundred dollars
yeah well look and ollie and i and i
love it and
uh and i'm glad y'all out there loving
animals and loving the essays baby them
small animals
you know when they had a guy used to
live by me his boy named chucky and he
used to
you know he'd smoke cigarettes and
you know used to [ __ ] supposed to be
putting the shopping carts away at dell
champs and he damn lied
and he was doing drugs but um
uh what i'm telling you look
a hamster is not a vettable animal
you know a hamster that's a damn look
it's not i mean it's
i mean it's that's a you know a ham
a hamster is not a vettable animal
brother it's a that's a to-go lunch for
a wolf
you know i really think you should just
let the lord work on him there brother
uh he took his blood pressure he checked
his heart rate this kind of stuff
a little bit strange to me any case they
also hit him with some antibiotics so we
were giving him antibiotics for a couple
weeks
and then uh he died he had they didn't
work
and so now we buried them in the
backyard
god is the number one veterinarian
okay god is the number one veterinarian
especially
for a hamster okay your hamster got to
cataract
that means it's looking for the lord
baby
your pony needs a hip replacement that
don't mean
spend 20 dollars to get little daisy a
new piss hinge
okay let the lord work that means the
lord got his
tool belt on and he ready to go
your frog has a lisp that'll mean it
needs a
speech therapy it needs a grave
a grave is the lord's lost and found let
the lord
collect them and refurb them you feel me
your hyena needs a chin bone well let
the lord
your kitten got a cleft palate well
let the lord your guinea pig
got a arthritis well ltl baby
let the lord y'all out here
tinkering with the man's work somebody
out in beverly hills got a
pet mosquito in a back brace [ __ ]
let the lord you trying to teach his
turtle spanish
[Applause]
y'all need to quit acting like god don't
do the work
and el hey
okay that's what i'm telling you right
there baby
and thank you for calling ali man you
got to be good over there brother gang
i got to tell you right now we'll get to
a few more calls then we have a guest
coming in
athletic greens the reason i take it is
because i don't like eating celery all
day
i don't like eating vegetables all day
i like to get me some and get me some
and go i like to give me a little agua
give me an athletic green snip over the
packet a little bit of green dust smoke
comes out
and that's a vegetable smoke and i pull
it out and i put a ice cube in and i
gotta
hit that thing like a jump
that's what i'm saying baby and that is
athletic greens
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens with so many stressors
in life
it's difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and that's true
you get up you're on the go you already
have somewhere to be tomorrow
that's the world we live in right now
you already have somewhere to be
tomorrow
so you're going to show up with a day
supply of vitamins and minerals inside
of you
you're going to show up on an empty tank
one
tasty scoop of athletic grains
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
foods sourced ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic
green superfood blend and more that all
work together to fill the nutritional
gaps in your diet increase energy and
focus
aid with digestion and support a healthy
immune system
all without the need to take multiple
products narrow it down
quit taking this and this and this pill
and this in injections doing this and
that the suppository
just to feel something
that's right simply visit athletic
greens.com theo
and right now athletic greens is
doubling down on supporting your immune
system
during these covet times and winter
months
they are offering our audience free one
year supply of vitamin d my god
that's a whole solar system of sunshine
and five free travel packs you want to
leave
your family fine take these for five
days you'll be fine
five free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit my link today
you'll basically never have to buy
vitamin d again no back alley vitamin ds
no touching people you don't know having
to do nasty stuff for vitamin d it's
over
simply visit athleticgreens.com theo and
join
health experts experts
athletes and health conscious go-getters
okay
around the world who make a daily
commitment to their health
every day twitter is a [ __ ] again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
theo and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
look i've got my mother on athletic
greens that's how much i trust
is your mother on it let's go
um let's take another call right here
we'll take one more and then we will get
to our guest
today hey theo my name is aaron
hightower
and hey aaron and thank you for calling
i like aaron man it's a name a mixed
name
could be p male or female pet anything
bro
mystery ghost even gang brother praise
god
i've been a video game programmer for a
couple of years worked with a lot of
folks
and i wanted to get your take on what's
called the simulation
hypothesis i think there was a
story that went around december 30th or
so
i hit fox news and it's been doing the
circuits i haven't seen
everywhere it's been but yeah
there's a guy michio kaku k-a-k-u
and he's got some comments on it but
yeah i wanted to get your take i thought
you would
give us an entertaining insight from
your perspective what it might all be
about
thanks for everything you're doing theo
huge fan take care
thank you very much aaron assimilation
hypothesis
by kakach all right this says
do we live in assimilation gauging
whether or not we dwell inside someone
else's computer may come down to
advanced ai research
or measurements at the frontiers of
cosmology
i have to pee okay i'm back um
you know do we live in assimilation do
we live in a computer
man it really a lot of it really starts
to
feel like it you know and i think for me
some of it is because of how much time i
spend on a computer
or next to electronics
you know it's gonna feel like it
it's gonna feel
i'm gonna feel like i'm locked into a
database of course i'm gonna feel like
i'm
probably being controlled by one i'm a
computer sends me an email it tells me
that email usually a lot of times tell
me what i need to do next where am i
going
i put it into a calendar so i go check
on a calendar
and the calendar tells me okay this we
have to be tomorrow two
three seven pm hear who hears who else
is coming
so it starts to be really that i'm
following
and storing things that are important to
me in an electronic world
so much so that
that i could easily see why if enough
people suggested
that we were living in assimilation
it wouldn't be hard for me to maybe feel
that way
that somebody was you know nintendo
switching me
especially a lot of people switching sex
as they get older
like somebody just you know
you know did l2 smash the right
uh l2 and then smash the r and then damn
you know larry's got a cop now
you know or bridgette wants some tits
now
and that's that could be something
that's happening
um
do i feel like it
i think if i start to give into that
idea
then that's not going to be good for me
i wonder how i would feel say if i cut
off all electronics for myself for six
months would i still feel like i'm in
assimilation
or would i just start to notice that a
lot of people are addicted to
electronics and electronica and digi and
digitalia
um
is also i don't understand sometimes if
we are say we're an assimilation
sometimes you know i remember sometimes
i would just leave the game on
i'd be playing playstation playstation
or something i would just leave the game
on i would go
that's what i worry about sometimes that
somebody started assimilation and then
maybe they got attacked or maybe they
went outside to get something and
somebody cut them
you know you know or really disembowel
them
and they're never coming back to the
machine
so it's kind of like in like war of uh
what is that thing called sim not
sims but um
bat it's like a battle thing where you
have crops and you know
hey donny get the wood you know hey
cheryl huh
won't you farm farm
so let you know it has that whole thing
going on and i wonder if sometimes that
is just
on that screen where they went outside
to get the mail somebody popped them off
and now they're never coming back to the
controls again so now we're just stuck
here on this one page where nothing ever
kind of happens
and we're starting to lose our minds a
little
but also i think we're just one little
ice age
or not even an ice age just like a real
you know kind of a it's gonna be chilly
out there today
age and
away from us having to get back to
ourselves and what
and what it feels like to just be
to connect with a different source we
spent so much time connecting to this
to this source that of course we've
start to feel like part of it
you know if i have seven pickles i'm
gonna feel like a list like you know
i'm gonna feel a little green baby you
feel me
and i'm gonna start believing in green
[ __ ]
so i think that's where i am with it i
never felt that the rest of my life so
it's interesting that suddenly now
within the past five years when we're
getting so
i mean my device is always with me it's
never more than 10 minutes before i
respond to a text usually unless i don't
want to
so or let's have to think about it
and that's scared that's crazy
so for me that evidence seems more
realistic
you know and i worry about the long-term
effects of us not having an imagination
anymore
and things like that
but i think if i start if now do i
believe that one day we won't turn you
know get into a.i where we just lay on a
floor with our mouths open
and somebody you know we go clock in at
work and we're just laying there all day
watching our avatar work
and that becomes another world yeah i
could see that happening
i could see a huge transition of wealth
in that way too because
then you only can earn money in the
avatar world
you know in this brainscape
so suddenly all the money whatever you
have on the outside doesn't matter
anymore
you know i think it is interesting
everything you know i don't know if it
always happens but it'd be interesting
if a great equalizer comes across
and it sets it all at zero again
and then you find out what's in you
oh am i doing am i just gonna cry am i
just gonna
am i just gonna think am i just gonna
judge am i just gonna blame
or am i is some little part of me that
still has a pilot light of damn
manhood and bravado and womanhood gonna
[ __ ]
flicker
and pick up a [ __ ] hard stick
and say let's go i don't know you know i
don't know
i do not
know riley mao is here
riley mao how you doing brother good
all right man um you know it's been a
while and people been asking about you
and uh i just wanted to know
what um the last we heard from you
you had a love in your life and you had
come across some love
and do you remember that i do okay good
and um and tell me about that the girl
madison was her name
and you guys uh and it kind of fizzled
quickly i remember is that something i'm
recollecting well or no
you're right yeah okay and uh take me
through a little bit of that you guys
had
how many dates did you go on uh just one
okay okay and it uh and then after that
what happened uh things just didn't work
out
between us so we just we just uh she
went back to
a different state and we just never saw
each other again
and when you say that things didn't work
out what does it mean because you really
felt
i felt like you were into this gal i was
indeed
um but you know hey things happen
like what i mean
i mean i don't want to get into too much
detail obviously um
but i mean it just i mean she basically
just
saw another guy she was interested in
another guy really
and did you ever meet this guy no no
he's he's in a
in the her state as well so
oh it's easy yeah so she's taking the
easy way out kind of
hitting on some a local guy yep
yeah i hate when chicks do that oh he's
in he lives in my state i'm gonna i'm
gonna hook up with him you know
um what um
what how what else been going on how and
has how has love treated you since then
has there been
anything new on the love horizon not yet
but
um but i you will be the first to know
what what when something happens oh okay
nothing has happened no not yet
okay and how uh how were your holidays
did you enjoy it did you do something
what did you guys do
you go to hawaii no my parents did
they're they're there right now
oh wow yeah they they left me there and
they actually left me in california
um went to hawaii and um
now i'm here and do you guys celebrate
christmas yes
that's awesome man good i'm glad you got
to adapt man
um what else man what else can uh
what else do we need to know i know it's
been a while and i'm glad that you're
here now and i'm glad to be able to
check in with you
um do you do you
have you been alive what have you been
what is going on
have i been alive yeah yeah i've been
alive
okay and what else man give me a little
bit more than that give me
have you been outdoors you've been
indoors um i've kind of been staying a
little endorsed just
because of uh covid okay um and is that
fear hitting your community a lot are a
lot of people going down
no everyone's like just saying screw it
let's go outside
do vietnamese people get covered a lot
or no
i have no idea
okay keeping it close to the vest
um riley mao you'll be uh you're
you'll be in uh the um christmas town
extravaganza
i will be exciting
exciting i'm excited to see that man and
i'm grateful that um
that you pop back in and i'm grateful
that you know hopefully we'll hear from
hear more from you what kind of ladies
if there's a lady out there
that really fancies a man like yourself
you know a small
you know not small but a still-growing
maturing uh
malleable you know uh eastern kind of
you know western kind of eastern man
what what type of woman do you think
does would deserve a man like you or is
a good woman
um i'm not i'm not a guy
to be too picky um
i mean just someone that you know treats
a guy right
simple as that do you feel like there's
did madison leave you feeling like there
aren't good women out there or did you
did it leave you hopeful or hope less
did you feel like
it it made me hopeful definitely really
that's awesome man and what um
what do you uh do you envision like uh
any future moves or women because that
was your first kiss right
right and do you envision like i'm sure
you started to fantasize oh this is
gonna go to another place like i've done
this with women you know it's like you
get the kiss and you think you're gonna
get
you know a double up you know and things
are going to go crazy and you get all
these crazy you know ideas and you get
sensuality creeps into your body
and next thing you know you're just
disgusted with yourself or touching
yourself
but do you uh how did you get
like how did you stop the fantasies and
stuff how did you get away from that
um i mean honestly i just
said or i just thought in my head you
know hey she wasn't the one
move on there's plenty of people out
there
there you go there's plenty of koi in
the pond right there
maybe we'll find you a love out there
riley you never know true
never know what happens and do you have
any other uh
any other words of wisdom
no
riley mao ladies and gentlemen man thank
you thank you so much for being here and
we hope you'll come back soon we'll see
you at the um
belated christmas talent extravaganza on
january 15th
8 p.m central standard time um
i don't even know let me think uh if
there was
a song oh i know what this
is i wanted to play this on the way out
um you guys thank you for supporting uh
this past weekend thank you for
supporting our sponsors
um you know we got some new get that
hitter merch that's out there
and uh a lot of stuff
but we don't have to get all to it all
today uh take care of yourselves
stay confident go saints go bills
and i'll see you guys on friday nights
[Music]
celebrate living
celebrate misery
you hold that soon we're gonna die
let's have some fun while we all die
celebrate dark days
celebrate all y'all bang
this is spencer jacob growl
[Music]
with never home
let's have some fun while we all died
[Music]
you guys be good to yourselves man you
guys deserve it love you see you next
time